PREDECESSORS.
WE REMEMBER OBAMA HARDLY DID AN
PRESS CONFERENCES.
BY THE WAY THE PRESIDENTS MAY B
SOME SAY HIS OWN BEST
SPOKESPERSON, BUT SHOULD THE
OFFICE OF THE PRESS SECRETARY
LAY VACANT?
WHAT DOES HE ACTUALLY NEED TO.
WHO BETTER TO ASK THAN TWO MEN
WHO HAVE HELD THAT DIFFICULT
POST.
THE FIRST PRESS SECRETARY FOR
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND NOW THE
SENIOR ADVISOR SPOKESMAN FOR
AMERICA FIRST ACTION.
ALL RIGHT, LET'S START WITH YOU
PRESS BRIEFINGS ARE KIND OF UP
IN THE AIR FOR THE TIME BEING
AND MY QUESTION IS THIS.
HE NEEDS MORE OF A POLITICAL
OPERATOR IN THE POSITION OF
PRESS SECRETARY THEN PERHAPS
PREVIOUS PRESIDENTS, ESPECIALLY
AHEAD OF THE 2020 ELECTION.
>> I DO THINK AND OBVIOUSLY I'M
A LITTLE TRADITIONAL, THAT IT
CAN BE VERY ADVANTAGEOUS FOR TH
PRESIDENT,  BUT IT DEPENDS ON
WHO THE PERSON IS AND HOW
TOLERANT THE PRESIDENT IS.
I THINK IF HE HAS WHAT I WOULD
CALL A HAPPY WARRIOR, SOMEBODY
WHO LOVES OF THE PRESIDENT,
BELIEVES IN THE PRESIDENT, BUT
DOES IT WITH A HUMOROUS TOUCH,
NOT A TURBULENT TOUCH, HE CAN
TURN THAT ROOM TO HIS ADVANTAGE
THE PRESS IS SO OVERWHELMING IT
BECOMES AN OPPORTUNITY FOR A
PRESS SECRETARY RATE IT LETS TH
PRESS IF THEY DO THE JOB RIGHT.
>> YOU STOOD THEIR DAY AFTER DA
DEALING WITH IT, AND PEOPLE SAY
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS A TOUGH BOSS
YOU CAN'T POLICE HIM, WE'VE ALL
HEARD THAT.
IT'S BEEN SAID ABOUT OTHER
PEOPLE TOO, BUT YOU STOOD THERE
AND YOU DEALT WITH THIS PRESS
DAY IN AND DAY OUT.
DOES HE NEED A PRESS SECRETARY
OR AS A KIND OF A SUPERFLUOUS
POSITION AT THIS POINT?
>> LET ME WITH MAKE SURE I WISH
HIM A HAPPY BIRTHDAY TODAY.
I DO THINK HE NEEDS ONE AND I'L
TELL YOU I WHY.
THE JOB AND HE KNOWS IT BETTER
THAN ANYBODY HE DID IT WITH
CLASS AND JUST AT THE LEVEL OF
INTEGRITY THAT BECAME A MENTOR
TO ME, BUT THE JOB THAT PEOPLE
SEE ON TELEVISION ABOUT 5
PERCENT OF WHAT HAPPENS FOR
THERE IS A FACILITATION OF
ACCESS AND INTERVIEWS TO OTHER
GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS TO
INFORMATION COMING IN AND OUT O
THE WHITE HOUSE WHETHER IT'S
PERSONNEL, EVENTS, OR POLICIES
SO THE PRESS OFFICE IS VERY BUS
ALL DAY LONG FACILITATING THESE
OTHER THINGS, LOGISTICAL
MOVEMENTS OF THE PRESS POOL, TH
PRESS ARRANGEMENTS FOR EVENTS.
ALSO SPEAKING ON A HOST OF OTHE
ISSUES REGARDING THE WHITE HOUS
THAT AREN'T ALWAYS EXACTLY THE
PRESIDENT HIMSELF SO OF COURSE
THERE NEEDS TO BE PRESS
SECRETARY IN THE PRESS OFFICE.
I WOULD DIFFER WITH ARI A LITTL
BIT BECAUSE THE PRESIDENT HAS
BEEN SO MUCH MORE ACCESSIBLE AN
ENGAGES SO MUCH MORE I THINK TH
BRIEFINGS SERVE THE UTILITIES.
THEY SHOULD OCCUR,  BUT MAYBE
NOT ON A DAILY BASIS.
TO ENGAGE IN THE PRESS, AS YOU
SAW WAS SARA, SHE'S OUT THERE O
THE DRIVEWAY ALL THE TIME ON
CAMERA TALKING TO THE PRESS.
THEY WANTED IN A BRIEFING ROOM
WHERE THEY CAN TALK ABOUT THEM.
THEY DON'T LIKE IT IS MUCH
BECAUSE IT DOESN'T WORK AS WELL
FURTHER CABLE CONTRACT THEORY
YOUTUBE VIEWS AND THINGS LIKE
THAT PART.
>> THINK THAT'S AN EXCELLENT
POINT.
THEY WANT TO BE THE LEAD IN THE
SHOW FOR THEIR NETWORK OR THEIR
AUDIENCE AND I GUESS THAT'S
HUMAN NATURE.
I WANT TO GET YOUR THOUGHTS ON
WHAT CNN'S JIM ACOSTA HAD TO SA
ABOUT SARAH SANDERS.
LET'S WATCH.
>> I THINK SHE ACTED AS ANOTHER
EMPLOYEE OF THE TRUMP
ORGANIZATION.
WE SHOULDN'T BE IN THE BUSINESS
OF HAVING REFERRED TO
JOURNALISTS OR ANY SEGMENT OF
THE POPULATION AS THE ENEMY OF
THE PEOPLE.
I THINK SHE FELL SHORT OF HER
DUTY TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AND
IT'S GOING TO BE PART OF HER
LEGACY.
I THINK IT'S A CAUTIONARY TALE
FOR PEOPLE WHO TO GO TO WORK FO
THIS PRESIDENT PART.
>> ONE OF THE MOST SICKENINGLY
PIOUS INDIVIDUALS IN THE PRESS
CORPS RIGHT NOW.
IS THAT THE PRESS SECRETARY
SERVING AT THE PLEASURE OF THE
PRESIDENT PRESIDENT QUESTION
MIKE SHE'S NOT SERVING CNN OR
FOX OR ANYONE ELSE SHE IS
SERVING THE PRESIDENT'S AGENDA,
AND OBVIOUSLY WANTS TO GET IT
RIGHT SHE DOESN'T WANT TO GIVE
THE ISSUES WRONG, BUT COME ON.
>> JIM ACOSTA JUST WROTE A BOOK
I WON'T BUY, BUT SOMEBODY SAID
THAT HE WROTE IN THERE AT THIS
DAY AND AGE IT'S TOO IMPORTANT
TO BE NEUTRAL.
YOU HAVE TO BE AGAINST PRESIDEN
TRUMP, THAT'S A PARAPHRASE OF
THAT TELLS YOU WHERE JIM ACOSTA
IS.
THE PRESS SECRETARY'S JOB IS TO
FIRST AND FOREMOST REPRESENT TH
PRESIDENT YOU ARE THERE
SPOKESPERSON PER YOUR JOB IS TO
TAKE THE PODIUM AND SPEAK ON
BEHALF OF THE PRESIDENT TO
REPRESENT THE ISSUES THE WAY TH
PRESIDENT WOULD REPRESENT ISSUES
.
IT HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH YOUR
OWN DEMEANOR, STYLE, OR
VIEWPOINTS ON ISSUES.
YOUR JOB IS TO DO IT THE WAY TH
PRESIDENT WANTS.
IDEALLY YOU DO IT ACCURATELY AN
ALL OF THAT MAKES IT A VERY
DIFFICULT JOB.
BUT MAKE NO MISTAKE, YOUR FIRST
BOSS IS THE PRESIDENT PAIRED.
>> EVEN GEORGE STOP ENOUGH US
TWO DAYS OF ACCESS TO THE PRESS?
YES OR NO.
>> I THINK WHENEVER PRESENT
TRUNK AND GET IN FRONT OF PEOPL
AND SHOW WHETHER TO JOURNALIST
OR A GROUP THAT IT IS A GOOD
THING.
>> LAURA: YOU DON'T HAVE THEM
IN THE OVAL OFFICE DATING OVER
THE PRESIDENT UNITED STATES.
AT DON'T LIKE THAT AT ALL.
>> THEY SHOULDN'T HAVE LET HIM
BACK IN.
>> HE IS A LITTLE TOO
COMFORTABLE IN THE OVAL OFFICE.
>> I WILL SAY THIS.
I THINK THE PRESIDENT, THERE AR
A LOT OF ADDITIONAL OUTLETS THA
HAVE BEEN VERY FAIR THAT DESERV